now to the farewell of the Queen of Soul
Aretha Franklin was laid to rest in a
mausoleum at a Detroit Cemetery Friday
that followed several hours of tributes
and songs earlier in the day at a packed
mega church on the outskirts of the city
to celebrate the life of the Queen of
Soul DeMarco Morgan was there Franklin
arrived as only she could watched over
by a caravan of more than a hundred pink
Cadillacs across a red carpet into the
church Aretha Franklin's homegoing
service was a joyful celebration how the
queen of Souls life
[Music]
preachers and politicians sit to the
podium to remember the lives she touched
ain't no cats over there in your cross
and pick up your crown
[Applause]
[Music]
she took this massive talent and this
perfect culture that racer and decided
to be the composer of her own life song
what a song it turned out to be Smokey
Robinson sang his tribute really gonna
miss you it's really gonna be different
with
but perhaps her grandchildren said it
best it feels amazing to see a woman so
fierce so courageous gifted so respected
and to be able to call that my
grandmother to know that I have that
running through my blood and that she's
a part of who I am
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so proud of you I know you'd be
watching me from the windows and heavy
and I promise to carry our family legacy
would pride and joy long live the Queen
thousands of fans waited for hours to
grab one of the 1000 seats set aside for
them for those who couldn't a nearby gas
station with a Jumbotron became a
makeshift sanctuary all benefiting the
eighteen time Grammy winner who passed
away two weeks ago at the age of 76 she
most certainly will be missed the
funeral lasted more than seven hours and
what it was all said and done her body
was escorted to the Woodlawn Cemetery
that's where she'll be buried with her
father and her two sisters along with
the late great Rosa Parks for CBS this
morning Saturday
I'm DeMarco Morgan Detroit ah that word
fierce she was all that and those shoes
the way I will I tell you the red
Louboutins that first day and her lady I
love fashion
we gallon she loved her sense of flair
with the shoe I'd tell you hitting a
queen really yeah it was it was a
fitting tribute to Aretha she deserved
all of that and more